Bella a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo video io sono Favij Oggi è
sabato quindi siamo in un nuovo vlog
prima di cominciare come al solito come
tutte le ex sacrosantissime volte
partiamo con la fan art della settimana
che è questa settimana è stata vinta da
Antonio che la fa e ce l'ho ce l'ho
fisicamente sto disegno della prima
volta è a parte i miei capelli
esageratamente sexy
[Musica]
Adesso va meglio A parte i miei capelli
fantastici Cioè ma che cazzo di disegno
della madonna eh C'è anche c'è anche il
castoro bellissimo ragazzi è
meraviglioso Vi adoro in una maniera che
non avete idea Vi giuro praticamente
Ragazzi questi disegni li ho ricevuti
Perché sono andato a fare i firmacopie
Allora molti di voi mi hanno portato dei
disegni e cose che tra un po' scarterò
Quindi è una sorta di scartaggio dei
pacchi Facciamo così tanto ragazzi
nell'ultimo firmacopie mi sono messo a
correre per strada Prima di entrare alla
Mondadori a firmare i libri volevo
vedere che cosa sarebbe successo quindi
ci ho provato questo è stato il
risultato
[Musica]
[Applauso]
ho perso l'udito da un orecchio Dammi un
orecchio Dammi un orecchio è stato bello
Un saluto saluto
Invece di far jogging la mattina faccio
questa cosa fa sudare parecchio
soprattutto se sei una persona timida
studia ancora di più questo ve lo
garantisco Comunque ragazzi passando
dalle news non ho praticamente nulla da
dire cosa meravigliosa l'unica roba che
voglio dirvi è Preparatevi al prossimo
cazzeggio Time Io credo che non uscirò
più di casa dopo quel video Credetemi
quindi Tenetevi pronti quindi ragazzi
detto questo Direi che possiamo passare
allo scartaggio dei pacchi Dio mio da
quant'è che non dicevo questa cazzo di
frase Ah che bello minchia è la prima
volta che lo faccio da tipo 4 mesi
Allora vediamo cosa c'è qua dentro prima
cosa c'è un nuovo e Tony Allora ecco
perché guarda che faccio la sveglio che
c'ha Ascolta Bobby Ehm sì ti appoggio
qua Eh la Madonna ma grazie love story
Minchia meglio di Twilight ragazzi
meraviglioso chi è che devo sposare per
questa di preciso delle fine perché mi
puzza il culo e per finire ragazzi Un
Action Figure di Mikasa ed è bellissimo
No vabbè ma è una figata
Perché cos'è sta cosa se un altro set di
baffi Ma come Ma quanto sono sexy così
Ragazzi io io io oggi esco così ragazzi
cioè vado fuori sono bellissimi dentro
sta secca ci sono delle meraviglie c'è
in poche parole ancora baffi Ma come Ma
basta la ragazza che me l'ha dato
trovata sexy baffi si vede Pop Candy
metti in bocca e scoppietta
Oddio Oh mio Dio Che strano Minchia
bruttissimo dei biscotti Minchia ma io
ti amo ma chi sei che ti sposo
immediatamente una barretta di
cioccolato coi Babba ovviamente coi
baffi perché senza i baffi ragazzi
ovviamente non andava bene Da quando ho
giocato al gioco dove c'era Tony Minchia
tutto coi baffi è impossibile caramelle
questo non c'hanno i baffi però Grazie
tesoro per avermi fatto venire il
diabete per avermi fatto esplodere la
mascella E per avermi dato dei baffi
sexy
più che sexy sembra un pornoattore degli
anni 80 quindi ragazzi detto questo
Direi che possiamo passare al Family
rispondere che anche questo da un secolo
che non lo faccio poi vi risponde Ciao
Favi fai la Charlie Charlie Challenge
spolliciate non ho mai provato a farsi
Ok ragazzi ci siamo allora ho preparato
sta cagata Tra l'altro notare la sex
agile delle mie calze che è qualcosa di
incredibile
anche nel gusto delle calze faccio
leggermente cagare però poi questo
questo è un dettaglio indifferente Vabbè
iniziamo Ah
ciao ciao
[Musica]
succede un cazzo raga Che merda
ricordiamo
[Musica]
l'ha detto Charlie e devo andare
Grazie Ciao Francesca Orsini fai vedere
i nomi che metti alle foto tue e mi
facevano morire quando l'ho vista Quello
che intendeva questa ragazza incredibile
credo che sia questo Cioè praticamente
esasperato esaurito
Che bello eh Faccia Lol Questa questa è
bellissima è horror Dog Hungry incazzato
proprio cioè volete mettere incazzato
incazzatissimo incazzatissimissimo Lollo
LOL nascondino Sì perché così non mi si
vede Oh my god troppo schieri ops ops Mi
sono cagata addosso orsacchiotto Pandino
spiegato in paura paura due pazzia Oh
mio Dio in pigiama in Umbra raping Time
qua me lo stanno mettendo nel CAP a
pranzi scarissimo certo zio paventato
Man spaventato ma anche sorpreso Vabbè
ovvio spaventosissimo stranito
sembra che abbia visto il pene di Rocco
Direi che posso concludere qui ragazzi
manca un museo e così divertente Mario
Martone fa mi risponde Beviti la tua
pipì
credi che io non ne sia capace zio Mi
stai mettendo alla prova
è una roba del tipo Ok
quanto figo e adesso ragazzi cin cin per
lo faccio per te
la prossima domanda No vabbè dai vi
spiego perché sennò la gente ma che
cazzo hai fatto bene era cedrata quella
roba gialla buona cioè potrei suicidarmi
piuttosto che fare una cosa del genere
però Ok Prima di concludere ragazzi
Volevo farvi vedere una mia invenzione
che ho inventato l'altro giorno che è
stata quanto strana e praticamente
ragazzi amplifica il suono del telefono
Praticamente quando fai così
[Applauso]
quindi ragazzi è il nuovo Art Attack by
Favij No vabbè questa roba qua la vendo
su eBay 12 mila euro ti spiego come
farlo ragazzi è una cagata assurda
Allora praticamente vi mangiate dei
biscotti oppure del cioccolato con dei
baffi dopo chiaramente mangiato tanto
Andate al cesso andateli dissenteria Ma
quella proprio forte Oh voi che avete
cagato abbondantemente finite tutta la
carta igienica che avete prendete questa
cosa qua che rimane alla fine della
carta igienica quando avete questa cosa
qui Ci attaccate semplicemente un
bicchiere a sinistra un bicchiere a
destra e voilà lo devo smettere di farsi
stronzate Sarà stata la pipì che ho
bevuto Comunque ragazzi concludo qui
l'episodio io ai miei baffi sexy vi
dobbiamo lasciare Spero che il video vi
sia piaciuto come al solito Se vi è
piaciuto lasciate un commento mi piace
anche la pagina di Facebook che come non
i video trovate nella descrizione Se non
siete iscritti iscrivetevi ci vediamo al
prossimo video bella ragazzi